welcome back to new rockstars how will
the end of the wanda vision bring about
the multiverse saga and the mcu
also what exactly is the multiverse saga
and will it include the muppets because
let me tell you
i've got a ranking and i'm here to piss
everybody off again
i'm jessica clements this is rogue
theory it's exactly what it sounds like
it's a show where i want to hear your
theories and they better be
x-men style rogues joining us today
our very number one resident mephisto
hunter aka
daddy eric voss
i'm so glad to be here in the trenches
with you guys figuring this [ __ ] out
oh my gosh people are gonna eat this
[ __ ] up wow
all right we have another returning
guest from rooster teeth kayla milton
how are you doing i'm doing pretty good
glad to be back and last
but certainly not least is our another
returning guest co-host of the
philosophers eddie villanueva
what's up guys i'm glad to be back again
and obviously you know what
it's gonna be great to get back into the
trenches with eric because eric tends to
come up with these really weird
ideas that i just tend to follow so i
mean let's go with it they're often
wrong
i'm sometimes leading you off a cliff
but you'll love to follow me on that
drop
it depends on your definition of truth
so my definition says you're mostly
right so i mean
hey you know my definition says you're
usually right oh goodness put that in
the back pocket don't ever say that
again because he's always wrong
sorry boss it's true let's get into it
though let's get into it
put vos to the side the mcu wrapped up
the infinity stone saga with endgame and
we've all been waiting and wondering
what's
next for the mcu there's been major
hints that the next thing is going to be
the multiverse saga
uh the multiverse gets name dropped in
spider-man far from home it's the title
of the new doctor strange sequel
multiverse of madness and loki obviously
is going to be delving into like
some time traveling like dimension
hopping happening
madness dimensions
and it's happening uh so my question for
this rogue theory for you guys is how
could one division
set up the multiverse saga nick i had an
idea about this i want to hear what you
guys think because
uh we found out in one vision that it's
set before even spider-man far from home
which is weird let alone spider-man no
way home and i'm wondering if like the
fact that
it is set uh in the weeks after avengers
end game
falcon winter soldier seems like it's
dealing with the aftermath of end game
all these things
are we looking at another nick fury's
big week you know remember like in phase
one they said that like uh iron man 2
captain america um thor
and uh the incredible hulk were all like
roughly in the same week leading up to
the avengers
maybe we're gonna be visiting a lot of
these other titles and we're all gonna
show
where they were as avengers end game was
ending and as the west view anomaly blew
everything up and we're gonna
check in with all these different
properties just because it seems like
no way home is gonna have to deal with
the immediate aftermath of far from home
uh and that's gonna lead directly into
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
and that all these things are gonna be
happening concurrently as opposed to
title six months after that next title
six months after that title
i have to agree with you because if if
you look at the way
every film had pretty much offered the
information uh right after
uh infinity war with the snap you had
all these you know
cut scenes the mid-credit scenes of when
you know the snap happened in their film
yeah and it was just catching everybody
up on the different facets of
what the snap looked like for nick fury
with ant-man and the wasp and pink pym
and with all these different people i
think
these film these shows are just going to
do exactly that they're going to fill in
that gap
to the point to where we get that one
moment that essentially
uh epitomizes what happens in this next
part of the saga
it's also like you don't know what's
going on the multiverse with what we're
seeing in one division also looks so
everything's moving so quick we don't
know time well we know where it's taking
place but we
things are moving so quickly in that
bubble that in the multi that's
it makes complete sense why you think
like instead of six months it'll be like
five days every day is a different movie
like if it's going to be like march 21st
march 22nd so i see that yeah i wanna
i wish you were wrong but i could see it
so with that being said
if we're connecting all five movies are
we saying that wanda will appear in
those next five
in the next movies do you think or do
you do you think she's gonna be the
villain going forward
i think for some reason so i i have this
romantic thought if you will
where in just prediction-wise at the end
of
wanda vision we're not only going to see
because in previous
new rockstars videos we did make the
assumption that possibly this may be the
end of vision's
appearance throughout the mcu at this
point in time
however i may feel i kind of have an
illusion that at this point in time at
the end of one division wanda is also
going to go away
and become this ultimate like cosmic
force that surrounds
the multiverse of madness and
not only is she going to be omnipotent
if you are omnipresent in the situation
but she's also going to have a hand in
every film
without actually physically being there
she'll be like lucy
or what's that scarlet movie where she's
just like technology now
exactly her exactly yeah
her yeah she's just a disappointed a.i
joaquin phoenix
she's just good at playing this
character and playing this role so
they're gonna have it
yeah yeah they were like oh you know it
would be good for a disembodied robotic
voice i feel like that scarlett
johansson would be fantastic
because someone said that name she goes
they go no scarlett johansson
what if scarlett johansson is the voice
of white vision sorry
now i'm going on it that'd be so
weird also people are saying that they
wanted to be
ultron's voice which would be super sick
but i don't think they're going to bring
back
by the time this video will have aired
there's a video coming out on the
channel that's already out on the
channel this time you're watching this
but
i kind of go into a theory of how ultron
might come back but i don't you know i
don't think it's gonna be his voice
because
it's like it's a weird cognitive
dissonance where it's like wait why are
you
why it's paul bentley's face why is it
ultron's voice and then also a lot of
people in other countries watch
this they'd be like oh they brought back
that one german voice actor
who dubbed ultron in the german age of
ultron to come back and they're like
it's not going to be there for them you
know it's weird yeah i want to translate
for the international audience you're
right you're right
that's right that's right hey you got to
think about the international audience
at the end of the day which i think
everyone's doing right now
do you guys think loki is going to be
set it seems like it's gonna be set
right as he tumbles out of that rabbit
hole when he escaped an
end game are they gonna reference like
the westview anomaly
is are we gonna hear owen wilson mention
westview and loki
well we have that one scene in uh in the
loki's show in the trailers where we do
have owen wilson's character
kneeling down to that little girl or
talking to the little girl and in the
background you have that stained glass
window
with that kind of devilish character
devilish so who knows
so who knows if i i feel like there's
more of a connection between what's
gonna happen in this show
and loki uh in terms of the front end of
things that are happening in the back
end of things that are happening
and kind of coming together to create
this sandwich if you will of
the events to come that are going to
start off this new saga of mcu
uh if i if i have to throw my hat into
the ring i think that
uh we're just gonna enter an age of
wackiness where everything is just a
what-if scenario between doctor strange
uh wanda and loki where it's just like
everything that you saw
doesn't exist was it real who's to say
timelines i don't know her
and it's just gonna be all like hey uh
in five years once we put all our final
movie in phase three you're gonna
realize what the real timeline was and
that's a moment sooner
it's gonna be mcu dallas where this just
opens the shower and oh you're still
alive
seems like they got half the writing
staff of rick and morty to be writing
all these next shows and movies right
like it seems like they want it to be
kind of a
madness um absurdist world where yeah
where nothing's really true
but then things can also be really dark
and meaningful
in some places i feel like that's gonna
be very true with loki they're just
gonna first off loki is
very going forward after the avengers
movies he was in he's very much like
comic relief so now he's getting his own
series and it's just gonna be like
can't wait to see all the craziness this
man gets into he's gonna
bomb everything by accident like it's
gonna be i feel like the trailer that we
did see
is only a little bit it's not gonna be
even half of what we expected
i agree with kayla where it's just like
yeah they're gonna just throw stuff at
us
you thought you thought or we thought
too much which happened with wanda
vision we just thought we overly thought
and we were like oh
it's that simple okay i get it so how
will titles like shang chi and the
eternals connect to the multiverse we
talked about
uh loki and how it would kind of connect
uh we also didn't really
we could talk about like how we think
spider-man will connect or even the
multiverse of madness
though i'm sure we kind of get it from
the sense of the title
but what about shang chi and eternals
yeah i'm wondering when
shang chi and eternals will be set like
eternals is gonna like go back
and forth from a modern era to like
ancient times
uh shang chi uh seems like
it could be set at any point really
because it's involving the ten rings and
the ten rings have been around
forever uh and the mandarin uh but
like uh i assume it's gonna be set after
after
iron man three and after uh trevor
slattery went to jail just because i
think that short all hail the king
is canon yeah right uh so yes
it seems like that was the real mandarin
being set up they could do a black widow
scenario and this is just set like after
civil war but before infinity war or
it's set during the blip i want to see a
movie that's set during the blip like
during that five year period because
there's so many great stories that they
could be told i hope they just don't
skip over that you know
shane she could be one of those or
eternals could be one of those because
you got a whole five years worth of
space of anything happening from the
beginning of sword
and you know seeing uh maria rambo
beginning that whole uh organization to
you have everything
there's so much that you can fill in
that space with and understand
more so about the implications the more
uh impact if you will of the decisions
with like with wanda and with vision and
whatever happens at the end of one
division as well i'm gonna be super
quick i feel like uh i'm not too
well versed on the eternals but my one
hope going back to what you said about
that five year period
is i don't know i feel like with uh the
three
uh with the you know the netflix shows
being out of netflix jail now
maybe that they want to go into that
five year period somewhere on disney
plus
i would love to see what those
characters did during the blip
if they didn't get snapped because you
know technically we don't know
so it's just like hey maybe i don't know
maybe jessica jones is just like vibing
in her apartment during the when the
blip happened
i think we're missing a really huge part
of those five years and that is
what happened with all the people who
blipped yeah where did they go
yeah oh i'd love to see that you know
and maybe there's some kind of
subconscious
programming or or abilities that were
imp imbued on them being within this
cosmic
sub plane if you will and recognizing
like through those five years
maybe all those people who blipped are
going to become
those mutants once they come in contact
with the
cosmic force the hex force i want that
to happen
so badly i want the okay to affect yeah
oh yeah i want it to affect so badly
that way
where i want to see what's happening in
that five years definitely but
we and we've talked about this boss i
want to see like more mutants come in
any form possible like in any way that
you can bring it into the world
and if that blip affected that situation
then i want to see
that happen and i i i feel like this is
something kevin feige's already thought
about is like i'm keeping in the back
pocket we already got
we got five movies coming your way you
hold up then we'll go back to the blip
like he is ready but i want that
i don't know i need them to bring in
some sort of like mutants this way or
any other type of that maybe we're not
talking about we talked about briefly
how
in one division how we thought when they
were like oh in space we lost a bunch of
astronauts and i was like oh
what if those are the fantastic four
like what if that was
like stuck in space oh i need it i love
it theory
yeah i love that there and i support it
yeah it's
it's a solid theory it's a solid theory
and it's like super economical like you
have this like
uh you know trans universe uh moment
that like affects everything why just
limited to what happened in infinity war
people dust away and they come back an
end game like
yeah you should bring in a fantastic
four that way something related to that
should be how mutants come about
hear me out what if all the weirdness
going on
uh with uh not maria the daughter's body
when she was going through the
wall for that last time what if that was
just reacting to all the blip chemicals
in her body
giving her mutant powers
[Laughter]
yeah they're putting blips in the water
and it's oh dude i am listen i'm i've
never been hyped for a marvel theory
until
exactly right now you're welcome this is
what rogue theory is about
go off on it the idea if they could put
the blip in the water and that's how
that's probably the most
theory i've ever thought about is that
you could get it from drinking water
everybody would be a superhero what were
they saying how in spider-man how like
they were gonna have all the other
spiderman make cameos for the multiverse
thing
they could easily do that with the
fantastic four and i would it would give
me
the most satisfaction because it would
it would only work
it would only work if they bring back
the 1993
the the the independent film for
fantastic four they would have to bring
not everybody like maybe the reed
richards who was in that one or
something i mean that would that would
that would kind of tickle my face i'm
here for it
they should try it i don't know if we
legally could do it
they could do anything at this point now
they might as well they should get a
test
on it they got a disney video it's the
house of mouse they can do anything they
want
yeah they'll make it legal so okay we
talked about it
and this isn't a competition like vaz
said it's not a competition but i'm here
to award winners and their theories
correct
yeah do what you want to do this is your
show so obviously i have to give
oh i get to rate everybody's voss
you get one cliff bar wrapper
yes you get one of these which is the
equivalent of like two sparkle bucks
oh very nice so because cliff bars have
a good amount
of calories kayla i'm gonna give you two
paint brushes
which is the equivalent of two sparkle
butts
eddie eddie i reacted
so wildly to the theory into your theory
that
i you guys all saw me react i'm giving
you
a half eaten bag of snap peas from
trader joe's which is equal i'll take it
to three sparkle bucks three sparkle
bucks
so yeah they're really good you guys
should try them out they don't sponsor
us
we're gonna go and theorize more about
falcon and winter soldier in a minute
but first we also have to talk about our
sponsors
who make it so possible for us to give
you rogue theory every week
starting with first we want to thank our
friends at calipercbd for sponsoring
this episode uh it's brought to you by
caliber cbd their cbd powder
fits into your routine while helping you
feel better
so their 20 milligram packets of cbd
powder are completely flavorless they
mix easily into any food or drink
you can bring them on the road with you
or take them to work wherever you might
need a little calming cbd influence in
your life
members of the new rockstars team really
like them for helping with soreness and
stress
they've been really helpful for
improving my sleep personally
caliber cbd comes in affordable 30 and
60 count packs
individual packets give you the benefits
of cbd wherever you go
caliper is completely thc free so all
the goodness of cbd
no hi so when i said take it with you as
you go on the road
that's right i'm not going to get
encouraging anything else so this is
just cbd it just gives you all the other
nice benefits of cbd so it's clinically
proven that you absorb 450 percent more
cbd with caliber cbd powder
compared to uh tinctures 450
that's a lot of percent get 20 off your
first order when you use that promo code
rogue at
tricaliper.com rogue and you could try
caliper cbd risk free for 30 days
if you don't love it they will give you
a full refund that's tricaliper.com
rogue don't forget that promo code rogue
for 20 off your first order
uh but jessica you wanted to talk about
someone
i have someone vos do you know what's
not fair
what life bus what's really not fair is
that netflix hides
thousands of shows and movies from you
based on your location
we knew this and it sucks have you ever
been to the uk and then you're like
wow rick and morty's on here it's
definitely not here on the netflix one
in my
country i have to get hbo max and hulu
well
if you use expressvpn you can make sure
you can get that
what's on netflix and your country is
completely different from what's on
someone else's in the uk or japan
using expressvpn you can control which
country you want netflix to think you're
in
you're going beyond this hackers the
movie that came out in the 90s think of
it as that except for it's legal
expressvpn has over 90 countries to
choose from
just switch to another country to unlock
their new shows like star check
discovery orphan black
rick and morty which are on the uk
netflix right now but not on the
american netflix it's not just netflix
also you can use expressvpn to unlock
shows on other streaming services too
like the bbc iplayer which i really
really need so i will definitely be
doing this
expressvpn works on your phone laptop
and smart tv so you can watch your shows
on the big screen
with zero buffering i buffer all the
time this is a problem of mine
was that just a mid-read buffer
because they knew me of all people
buffer the most so be smart stop paying
full price for streaming services and
only getting access to a fraction of
their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
rogue don't forget to use the link so
you can get three extra months free
free that's enough to say it that's
expressvpn
exp res s vpn
dot com slash rogue expressvpn
rogue to learn more so new rockstars
also wants to thank stereo for
sponsoring this episode we have been
partnering with the stereo app on weekly
live shows
you download the stereo app for free at
stereo.com
new rockstars so we're trying to do
these shows
every day of the week on mondays our
editors uh dissect some of their
favorite moments from our week of videos
they kind of make fun of me in that show
which i i need i i need a backup course
to be like
what the [ __ ] are you saying
any goddamn sense so that's what they do
in the show and then on wednesdays
philip and i go through the week of
entertainment news we kind of go through
the headlines and stuff that we haven't
covered in other videos
on thursdays off-screen producer zach
and brandon preview
that week's wanda vision episode so i
think later today based off when this
video comes out uh go on stereo be able
to listen zach and brandon
preview what will be in this one
division finale uh we'll be doing the
same professional winter soldier when
that comes
uh and then on fridays that's when
jessica and i do our live our
inside marvel one division after show
you can hear it hours before it's on
youtube that'll be tomorrow morning
uh and then after that we wrap on that
we do a bonus q a segment
uh with listener submitted questions
that goes on our youtube channel
on sundays so you get to be a star if
you just go on stereo and submit your
question there
the world will hear your beautiful voice
oh and by the way you can go back in
here any of our previous episodes of
these shows on the stereo app which
i should be very worried about because
you know i say stuff on that stereo app
that i don't say
other places and i if you want to cancel
me go to stereo
there's probably something there that i
should not have said
you can access these live shows share
your questions and theories interact
with us
in real time by downloading this free
stereo app at
stereo.comrockstars.stereo.com
newrockstars jessica you were saying
let's talk about falcon in the winter
soldier so falcon in the winter soldier
series was originally scheduled to come
out before
juan division so how affected will it be
by the multiverse drama
of west view if any at all
will it say so i want to hear your
guys's theories it seems like the math
to this is already like
expect nothing but we don't know there
might be a lot affecting it
i mean guys it seems like this show
won't at all deal with like rick and
morty madness nonsense that like loki
and
other titles will but there is that one
question from the end of end game
where old man cap shows up hands the
shield off to sam
bucky's there and that's kind of the
impetus of how
falcon winter soldier begins but like
according to the directors the russo
brothers
that old man came from an alternate
history
uh in order to get to the mcu now the
screenwriters say
he was just there the whole time in the
mcu as we've seen it but if we're going
to take the directors at their words
there are some multiversal questions
that got to get answered by the falcon
winter soldier like this shield
is an alternate shield from an alternate
timeline just digging into the mysteries
of that shield
might open the door to the marvel
multiverse
if they want to play it that way well
that's not to say that the shield itself
isn't imbued with some kind of cosmic
power as it transitioned from one
universe to the next
you know that's what makes it so unique
because we haven't we haven't really
touched on that with
where exactly in the realm of parallel
universes
does falcon and the winter soldier take
place oh
consistently you know because for all we
know the
beginnings or however at some point in
time something may happen
uh that may transition over to a
different universe i mean we get that
one scene
in the trailer where we have this wall
of
of heads um that has yet to be defined
or explained
and uh i feel like that could be part of
the glimpse of
maybe there might be some transition
over to another universe
during the course of the show that the
falcon and bucky find himself in
um to try to figure out what's going on
in the world
yeah i uh i kind of made a boneheaded
call in a video saying that those heads
were scrolls
and they weren't scrolls i think someone
shared a set photo i don't always look
at set photos because sometimes they're
a little too spoilery for me
but i think there it might be something
in the comics and magipor called like
the
uh brass monkey club
the brass monkey club it's something
like the brass monkey bar
i mean that's your definition of truth i
know mine hey you have your hunches
oh god that's true okay
damn okay so we have two people beefing
on this side
this is rogue theory guys we don't fight
here
we just come up with insane ideas
i like the idea of that also going off
of what voss did say
since we are seeing an old cap is
there's do you think there's like an
opportunity that they will
well i guess it's coming up before one
division i do want to go
they have already gone back in time and
like we've seen like
young tony stark's dad all the time
so i mean there's nothing really
stopping us from going back and seeing
old cap
would he have the idea oh my gosh he's
getting into math
would he still he would still have the
same consciousness of the cap
that showed up and gave uh falcon the
the shield right i think the
consciousness of cap at the time up
until
the end of end game
is what is what steve rogers takes back
with him to the past
carrying all that information up until
that point when he meets up
again with sam jessica just okay hear me
out bear with me
everybody please bear with me this is
this is going to be this is insane
i know it's not valid i know it's not
realistic but here's what i'm hoping for
after the success of one division i feel
like they wanna they're gonna do a
couple reshoots
they're gonna lean into the zaniness
we're talking about comic books anything
can happen
hear me out old cap becomes a nick fury
type character who gives
the falcon and the winter soldier like
weekly missions and it's like a buddy
cop thing but it's set like a 90s like
or no not 90s like an 80s miami vice
he's got a mustache she's got an impala
they're doing
quips back and forth at each other
there's yellow tinted cameras because
you gotta show that it's sunny and funny
and i feel like that ideally that would
be my
version of the show i don't think i'm
gonna get that but if that's what the
show ended up being
i absolutely would not hate that to just
have like that kind of buddy cop dynamic
where they're just like
ripping on each other and just like
punching bad guys in the elbow with
their elbows and high-fiving over a car
i would love that yeah dude they could
have done that they could have done
that that's the thing
and that's not out of the realm of
possibility too yeah i mean the way that
trailer went
they're just they're having fun you can
tell the actors are having fun and the
characters are having fun so
that honestly doesn't sound too out of
the realm of impossible i mean that
seems very plausible
that's like a charlie sanchez kind of
thing right like his voice like
i know angel just because i have wings
doesn't make me an angel steve
no exactly that's exactly what i want i
wanted to be that
level of camp i wanted to be that level
of fun i'm talking
low stakes hijinks between these two
characters who have only known drama
and trauma and i mean if you take the
events of wanda vision
and you incorporate the multiverse kind
of setup
it's not out of the realm of possibility
where steve takes on the moniker of nick
fury where
we've seen in past comics before any red
con
nick fury was the white guy yeah you
know him carrying a patch
i mean in another universe wherever
steve is at maybe the guys
travel over there end up over there and
report to him and he just carries the
moniker of nick fury and they're like oh
we know nick fury you're not nick fury
yeah and that kind of thing and i want
it to be chris evans
dressed as nick fury but he's doing his
best samuel l jackson impersonation the
entire time
he's got a bad mother wallet
they're just like steve steve no just
steve just stopped he's like no i can do
it
i want this to happen so bad luckily
this show is rogue theory so that theory
is extremely
rogue that theory is so good
it's grounded and rogue at the same time
which
as an improviser i didn't think those
two worlds existed in the same like a
venn diagram you can't be
rude and grounded that's no i guess you
can be
maybe i'm just not a good improviser but
i've never heard of that i paid a lot of
money for classes let me tell you
that's next level improvisation that's
what it is it's next level
oh my god it just reminds me of the last
um of the end of deadpool 2 where they
just straight where he's just time
traveling and just
messing everything up that's what he
could jump into and that would be the
case would be
just like like miami vice style just
like
so chief like coming in with both of
them have the mustaches
don't have the metal arm
he still fully has the metal arm but
he's got like
really shitty tattoos on it
[Laughter]
some artist is out there that should
draw something that is exactly this
and i would purchase it i would buy it
oh fully
i would buy that doujin immediately name
your price
i'll pay it yeah i'll pay you i'll pay
i'll subscribe to your patreon
yeah is that where you post it i will do
it dude
let's go the idea of that happening
is so i'm struck by it it
hit a nerve
i need that to happen i would hope that
old cap comes back
somehow in the next um in the
winter soldier and falcon story but i
don't know i don't know
i also think like when i say old cap i
guess like
chris evans captain not the old old not
the actual old cap that we saw
last um but i think he's kind of done
isn't he chris evans he's like i'm
finished well he's coming back in
two more movies but it sounds like he's
gonna be playing like his younger self
it sounds like it'll be like in an
alternate time like we'll like we'll see
cap in that alternate history maybe
dealing with like wolverine or something
well that's my hope this is everything
is so
up in the air comic books magic
multiverse
anything can happen we could get the
miami vice star witches
we could get wanda showing up being the
villain for this miami vice style
oh i'm never gonna stop dreaming i'm
gonna have a i'm gonna have a nice
night of sleep thinking about this oh i
have to award for that i
keep forgetting because it's so rogue
and i forget the meaning of this show
sometimes
it's supposed to be rogue theories kayla
i'm giving you
four four cliff wrappers if i ate that
many today i would give you all four
but i only have one so one cliff wrapper
the equivalent of four sparkle butts so
that's four points
miami you got me you got me and i'm an
aesthetic
person and i love miami vice uh eddie
another smashing smoshing i can't do an
accent i'm sorry but if i could i would
have said like awesome powers
boss can you do it for me baby i can't
do it either that was good that was good
yeah oh my god i loved it what is where
are my points
i'm giving you um one
computer aerosol can spray but i keep
spraying and i think i'm accidentally
getting high off of it so i stopped
using it
it was i think i sprayed too much i was
like it smells weird if you start
feeling high that's where you lean
into it and you keep spraying it until
you pass out
which is the equivalent of two points
eddie ah
plus two kayla's got plus four boss um
boss a million points i think you
deserve no million never mind
okay at least one for that accent i mean
you're
always one for the accent and i'll give
two for the theory because your theory
was very sound
it was very sound i would have given you
two before anyways but one
extra because of the voice i don't
remember what my theory was
but i'll take it i'll take the point
take it i'll take the sparkle butt so
that leaves us right now we have eddie
at
five sparkle booties uh voss
at five sparkle booties and kayla at
six sex zombies
so now we're getting into the real
questions baby which these are the do or
die
okay so the real questions wink wink so
somehow so and i love this i love this
question more than anything because i
didn't really think about it until i saw
we started getting into this work there
somehow uh hayward and
um and sword just let
the body of corpse get taken away they
took that body
underneath the avengers noses i feel
like that's impossible right
so the avengers one of the avengers must
have messed up and let hayward and sword
take that corpse out of here there's no
way you took the dead body of one of the
avengers one of the strongest avengers
and just was like oh no one's gonna know
so which
from you guys which avenger and why
let visions corpse just disappear like
that
i think they took it from uh from
wakanda rather than taking it from
from the avengers just because i think
in in the
aftermath of everything going on
somebody had to be aware that there was
a huge
situation happening in wakanda um there
at that point in time had already bunch
of trade there was a starbucks there i
mean
come on you know so there had to have
been some official peoples there and
when all that was happening
you know the military came in and while
everybody was still kind of gathering
themselves
that's true and wakanda just let them
take it well hannah was like go ahead i
don't want this body
uh i think it would have been hulk uh
bruce banner
just because like i bet that new sword
facility at cape canaveral has like a
great dining hall where it's just
breakfast around the clock
and hulk's just like you mean i could
eat as many sausages
wrapped in pancakes as i want okay yeah
if you want visions corpse you can just
take it
it's a shirt just like eating a bowl of
eggs
i'm gonna say it's thor and i'm gonna
say it's because his haircut appointment
to keep his sick
fade up uh went a little bit long and
while he was getting
done up at the barber he just like
laughs and he was like was late to his
shift and
when they weren't looking he was just
like i'm just gonna take this vision
buddy and when they got back it was just
like
oh by the gods i'm sorry i was getting
my fade
super wet and then just like missed it i
have a question for you guys
any idea on who this final cameo is
going to be
the famous one that paul benny was
talking about yeah because i don't think
he it's happened yet and then we still
got one more episode
yeah final bets we got hours away right
i still think i have a theory i have a
rogue theory if you will give me it
so in 2015 in 2015 paul bettany did a uh
did an interview with a uh with an
outlet from the philippines
and he had mentioned that there were
three people that he had been wanting to
work with
for a long time one of them was marlon
brando
one of them was robert de niro and the
other one was al pacino
obviously marlon brando's out of the
question yeah if we're looking at a
mephisto
devil type character which out of those
two that are still around
has had history in playing a devilish
character
maybe al pacino as mephisto pops out of
nowhere
and we get like a devil's advocate kind
of thing going on he talks about
vision's ass he's like he's got a big
ass
it would be so wild if they did al
pacino but al pacino's
he's so used to doing such crazy roles
it wouldn't surprise me to see him
in this exactly after jack and jill
nothing's off the table yeah that's true
let's be honest i think it's himself i
think he was just being a
a kooky guy and being like i want to
work with the best of the best
he's been a kooky guy and he just was
hyping up himself which is nothing wrong
with that but i do think it's him
no i think it's him who knows i hope
it's keanu
i want keanu it's probably not
but that's what i want going back to
rogue
sorry i was adding up the points again
i don't want to be this person but i'm
going to be this person maybe i
shouldn't be hosting rogue theory
i love a crazy a crazy backwards ass
rogue that doesn't seem
like it is practical but it made me
laugh a lot
giving that point to kayla because
that's the idea
of thor being like nah i gotta get this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] lined up
literally listen you have to make that
appointment with his barber two weeks in
advance
he truly didn't he's like i'm not losing
my spot
i can't miss it i can't miss it also i
don't really care about vision
we kind of got in a fight already and it
didn't work out okay
last last rogue last road last rose
comic con 2021 will be
you guessed it virtual again what's the
worst part about having a comic-con
like from home or i guess what's the
worst part about not having an
in-person comic-con i'll say the thing
i'll miss the most about
uh comic-con is of course
the q and a line uh who doesn't love
uh endless line of people asking a panel
of wandering questions usually it's
someone
will you read my script uh feige
oh how i'll miss the long q and a line
of uh i have a treatment you should read
it
i i think one of the things i i don't
miss is the long walks from
from the convention center to my hotel
yeah like
i've already walked all the way all
around this convention center i got to
walk back to my hotel room
someone called everything with you and
then you just stay there for like
18 hours
i literally bring a backpack full of
everything i'm like i'm not going back
to the hotel
solicit yourself to the hall h people
there you go
i'm just like oh screaming standing
still against a wall
while someone forcibly takes a photo of
me yes i've been to conventions
and yes everybody hates it ask first
don't be crazy
just take a photo of me someone ran up
and snapped i wasn't even dressed up
[Laughter]
who do they think you're cosplaying
against some idiot i guess
because
i was so confused and i remember i was
like with my friends and they were like
why do you know that guy was like
obviously i don't know that guy if i
knew that
he would have done that right i'm sure
he would have said hi first and then
took the picture
yeah jessica what's up nah this man ran
up snapping
and i was like i know it's blurry too
because i was like
freaking out it was wild okay kayla what
do you miss
what are you or what's the worst part of
not having an in-person comic-con to you
the worst part about not having an
in-person comic-con
is i won't get to look at my credit card
uh
statement the next month and see that i
did in fact spend seven dollars on just
a bag of cheetos
just a bag of cheetos in the uh exhibit
hall
in the convention center yeah yeah the
damn i bought a waterfall
once i think the worst convention water
i've ever had
was like uh i was at it was the austin
uh convention center and it was like
nine dollars for like a 16 ounce bottle
of water
and it was some brand i never heard of
and i it it wasn't even
fully cold because i think they had like
just stocked the coolers
like restock the cooler so it was like
tepid at best
and i taste it and it just tastes like
you know you leave a a bottle of water
in the car
and it tastes like plastic it was just
yeah i expensed it though it's fine that
wasn't my money
oh my gosh i miss i miss having
in-person comic-cons more than anyone
would know
um if you look at my instagram i
literally will dress up and take
pictures in my bathroom
and it doesn't serve justice it doesn't
do it right
i need to do it in front of a bunch of
people i need to also be dressed up as
the same character as everybody else
um i miss it but i will give that rogie
to vos because even though it was ironic
it is the the the nerves i have at the
edge of my seat
at a q and a hurts it's like i'm
literally like
please no one at please no one asked no
one asked literally i went to a sesame
i was like no it wasn't seth um no it
was michelle nichols from
star trek and if you know nichelle
nichols she does not want to talk about
star trek she is
tired of it and they kept being like
what do you think of zoe saldana playing
your character and i was like
don't ask her i was like don't ask her
she doesn't want to talk about it
she was yeah set phaser is off a stun on
that one
there you go to kill is that is that
better or worse than when somebody
like walks up and they're just like uh
or do you
um do you know about this ship and then
everybody in the audience inhales all at
once
yeah i think that's worse yeah
yeah god i miss them though i miss
i miss i miss buying everyone's stuff i
miss buying everyone's things
ending score we got eddie
five sparkle booties they're not sparkle
booties but i like calling him that
uh boss i did not write this point score
right because on this it says boss has
12 points that is not correct
one looks like a six and i know that
sounds not correct
everything looks like a six to me there
you go
oh that made me feel bad i was about to
say i'm a six
that's like wait a minute i want to be
like a 12. okay
you have six points congrats second
place
but the winner of this rogue theory
because they
touched my heart too much is kayla
with seven points kayla you won rogue
theory
i've never won before oh my god
the the trick is getting me as the host
and saying some crazy
theory listen all i do is say
crazy [ __ ] uh it's honestly an issue uh
i shouldn't do it but here i am i'm a
sucker for those theories that miami
vice one literally turned me on my
if they could do it they could do it and
i'm so obsessed with that
god okay okay thank you for joining us
for another episode of rogue theory i
want to thank our guest
eddie kayla and boss um really quick
will you guys
each say where to find you uh i'll go
first uh you can catch my podcast the
philosopher's podcast on
anywhere you can find podcast streaming
and on social media at film uh
facebook.comlossers and on instagram and
twitter at philosophy101
you can find me on twitter at the
underscore indoor kid
i also have a podcast launching tomorrow
which for
us is march 3rd you can find it wherever
podcasts are it's called
no dumb answers with mark and brad which
is interesting because i don't know if
you know this my name is neither of
those things
uh it's a high concept podcast and if
you listen to it i think you'll like it
awesome you can also get updates about
the podcast at askmark and brad on
instagram and twitter
neither of those are my name i love it
you can find me at eavos on instagram
and twitter or just like click
on one of the videos that's on the side
it's probably gonna be
me on this stupid blue background
talking about some stupid [ __ ]
that's gonna be proven wrong by
tonight's episode of one division
have fun with that guys have fun with
that
and you can follow me as lulu clemens
literally anywhere on
twitter though it's lulu underscore
clemens because someone else stole my
name
support our channel by checking out one
of our many great merch options on new
rockstarsmerch.com
and follow new rockstars don't forget to
subscribe
like and follow subscribe like and
comment
it's youtube do whatever you want oh and
a quick reminder to download that stereo
app go to stereo.com selecting
rockstars you can listen to our uh
hopefully week
week daily live shows uh including
inside marvel with me and jessica
tomorrow morning
uh stereo.com new rockstar
[Music]
you